hi Kelly Thomson active returning
officer do you've noticed that the
number of roles for each candidate at
the election and a member of parliament
and the brighton pavillion constituency
are as far as Chris Bowers Liberal
Democrats 1525 Nigel David Carter you
get 2724 Caroline Lucas Green Party
22,000
that was 20 2871
parents Eden Mitchell the Conservative
Party candidate twelve thousand four
hundred and forty eight our pilot the
Socialist Party of Great Britain ATH
Turner said Labour Party fourteen
thousand
that was 14900 for Nikki Elmer's
independent 160 the number of ballot
papers rejected was as follows once an
official mark 36 voting the more than
permitted number 53 unmarked or
uncertain 97 that gave the number of
total rejected votes be 196 as I've
already said the turnout was seventy one
point six seven percent and I declare
this is due
I got among the returning officer and
has staff all of their amazing work in
this election and all that very bring on
work since the early hours of running
I'd also like to thank the other
candidates for the way they love their
campaigns and I hope in the future that
we'll have the chance to work together
for the benefit of the city the pathan
is a huge thank you to my own supporters
here tonight across the constituency and
be able to work so tirelessly during
this campaign there are so many to
mention how to my campaign manager path
steam I hate and so many more you know
who you are who have worked tirelessly
I've been privileged to work with you
thank you so very very much for all of
the hours that you've put in tonight's
victory is your victory also to pay
tribute to my family for all their
support they should you are my rock
Isak fear thank you so much for one of
your support and only goal of five years
ago I stood here and said together we
him right in the made history but
tonight we've gone further we show them
not only how we win elections but we can
represent the people
five years ago I feel so pledged to
serve the people of this city as best I
could
thank you for putting your faith in me
again it has been a huge huge privilege
to represent the people of Brighton
Pavilion this is an incredibly special
place it is creative compassionate and
brain and I'm proud to call it my home
apartment it starts on the streets it
starts in people's homes in the
workplace
Brian weighs history in 2010 by electing
me as the first queen hanpei because
here we make that kind of politics real
because we made politics about giving
people hope not filling them with fear
tonight we make history again in
Brighton and nationally thanks to the
thousands of people up and down the
country this is the greens were
successful election campaign ever with
almost a million people going to here I
also want to say that I think tonight
has shown that our political system in
this country is broken it's ever clearer
tonight that the time for a lecturer
phone is longer with you and it's only
proportional representation that will
deliver a power that is truly just
legitimate and the
tonight is also that those of us who
want a clearer more progressive politics
have to find new ways of working
together to achieve it even also in the
face of what looked like five more years
of savage austerity there are
alternatives and results in right the
villain tonight shows that people will
vote for it
so together we need to find new ways for
putting these new politics into practice
thank you